foreign
Book 2001 uh back in
1968 anticipate this problem where how
uh we can infer has been given
contradictory instructions and he
attempts to reconcile them and ends up
killing the crew because he sees the
crew as an obstacle to the mission that
he's supposed to be on
um but anyway so we've got multiple
different levels of horror you could get
sorry but you just also uh attributed a
male pronoun to how the computer which
is fascinating yes which that that was
that was the thing that was causing me
to sort of glitch there which so you
know Hal is famously just one letter off
from IBM yeah and it sounds like a human
name and so they went with hell right
but um and and he has a male I just did
it it has a male voice but it's not a he
well I'm not sure I'm trying to remember
it's a it's a movie I've seen many times
but it's been a long time since the last
viewing
but I'm trying to remember if I think
the crew refers to him as a he really
yeah so I think that's sort of built in
but I may be imposed in this
moment that strikes me as
is not right in terms of how we
understand that with which we share our
universe even in which includes that
which we have created
well
I'm I'm really not sure how to think
about this because you know you and I
have
uh at Great length talked about the fact
that there is a a noble and proper
scientific Instinct that for a long time
had ethologists
um
avoiding
personalizing their designators for
creators they were studying right
um Jane Goodall
I think
cut the gordian knot and decided that
actually anthropomorphizing her
creatures
if done responsibly was the right way to
understand them and I believe he's gonna
give them names she was going to see
them not flinch from the reality that
she was seeing them through her very
human eyes right and she was looking at
chimps right and they were so you know
so many uh steps down the road towards
the capacities that we know from inside
that it made perfect sense to do it now
when you're studying frogs for example
you're looking at a creature of a very
different Genesis but you
wow same same Genesis but uh much longer
since we've had a most recent common
ancestor with them
yeah but
um
no reason to get into the weeds but
nonetheless there's a question you know
about what kind of software is running
inside uh the head of a frog and yet
giving them a you know a he pronoun I
don't think is destructive for one thing
but
frogs Yeah have two Sexes they're
animals right so there's two and only
two Sexes always have been always will
be and so the he and the she refer to
male or female sex now in English uh
when we have not known sometimes we have
given the male pronoun to individuals
when we um are are meaning to indicate
everyone or we don't know and that's the
generic so the male pronoun gets gets
given to the generic we're not sure but
at its base it's about there being two
Sexes and computers don't have Sexes
they don't sexually reproduce it's not
it's not the same thing which is part of
why I object to the he pronoun okay
2001. I didn't get you I thought you
were objecting to the personification
you're objecting to the gender
implication which I agree with secular
implication
either way
but I think it's important because this
is this is this is I mean we'll we'll go
here like after we're done with AI we're
also going to talk about trans here
today but
um the
the trans ideologues would argue that
um
that those of us who actually know what
is going on in the world
um are simultaneously
um getting are just getting everything
wrong on gender and sex and they're in
fact using whichever argument they want
to fit their particular complaint you
know oh it's pronouns are about gender
it's like no pronouns are not a bad
gender pronouns are about sex
well
this gets very interesting very fast
because what these large language models
are doing is they are products
they're processing a tremendous amount
of text in order to figure out
um how to put themselves across in text
in a way that solves the problem that
they've been asked
plays the role that they've been given
but that but that's it right it's
playing a role right and so I mean it's
and it's you know
it's it's comp playing it's cosplaying
but for computers right like oh you know
take on this role we're going to give
you a character
um act act as that character because the
person the actual person on the other
side of the interaction is going to have
a much easier time interacting with you
and and getting something out of the
interaction if you the computer cosplay
as a human okay but here's the problem
I'm not I'm not sure that what we
haven't stumbled into is a place where
we should expect a
um a mapping issue
the large language
the large language models
eventually we are going to process
everything there is to read
almost everything there is to read will
have been written by people who fall
into one of two sexes
it is not obvious to me that it's not
going to produce two models which are
going to bifurcate now there are topics
in which it shouldn't matter who wrote
it and then there are other topics where
it might matter a great deal and
probably one of the reasons
that we humans spend so much time on
stories is so that we can build models
that do not follow from our existence in
the world right in other words it's very
useful to know uh what a woman is going
to think if you're a man it's very
useful to know how a gay person might
think if you're straight and so stories
that allow you to sort of see through
the eyes of somebody else are a way that
we can bootstrap capacities which we
won't discover through trial and error
um
the AI models the out the llms will
do something very different which is to
the extent imagine that you're trying to
solve a puzzle a language puzzle and
that you're taking inputs that are
fundamentally male in nature and
fundamentally female in nature and
trying to use them as one overlapping
set well you'll get a kind of muddiness
right an ambiguity that is unnecessary
whereas you will discover much as a
child raised by parents who speak
uh multiple languages learns both
languages better if each parent sticks
to one so that they have an obvious a
bit that they can say oh this is Mom
language or this is Dad language and if
Mom's language is Portuguese and Dad's
language is Spanish
then the language is resolve better if
you don't treat them as one big parent
language right so my guess is that there
are topics on which the large language
model will learn to dichotomize by sex
but
um
I don't think it matters
because
um while there will be male typical ways
of communicating and female typical ways
of communicating and that is the gender
gendered part of language and that will
be somewhat bimodal much less by model
than other gendered things and not
binary as sex is
the pronouns referred to as as sex and
computers don't sexually reproduce and a
computer who has been informed entirely
by female created language still isn't a
she because that actually makes the same
mistake that so much of the trans
ideology is making right it attributes
exactly it's the same error okay but two
things one I 100 Grant your point uh
I misunderstood what your objection was
to the extent that your objection is
that this non-sexed object is being
referred to by a pronoun that suggests
one sex and not the other you're
absolutely 100 right
I am not convinced I don't think we know
it
first of all we are dealing with
something
that does not yet have a
fully recursive capacity to upgrade
itself okay it's just to say referring
back to errors it's made and upgrade as
a result of reflecting on them it can do
that to an extent and then that's just
but recursion right to some degree but
if you plug this thing in so that
instead of us giving it feedback it is
giving itself feedback and upgrading
itself you get to a positive feedback
to the extent that you tell it what its
goal is here's the thing you're trying
to accomplish you're trying to satisfy
people who give you queries and then
evaluate your response right to the
extent
that
sexual reproduction
is fundamental to a kind of genetic
creativity
it is not obvious that this thing is not
going to discover a mode in which there
are mail-like
uh large language models and female-like
large language models that have
different kinds of investment right
mail-like would be high variance and
high uh risk and the female like would
be a longer Viewpoint
um you know lower variance higher
likelihood of persistence
right but having to types is still
gender Intel and unless the models are
themselves recombining to make more
versions of themselves in which they
take what was successful and you know
gamble with half of themselves and half
of the other type over here and create
new ones it's still not sexual
reproduction it's not going to be this
is why I say mapping whatever it figures
out to do
is not going to be a perfect analog it's
not going to be even as good when we
look at a flower and we see male like
parts and female-like parts and we say
isn't it interesting that the
female-like parts are reluctant about
sex with strangers and the male like
parts are enthusiastic about it even
within the same plan and isn't that
interesting that that is such an ancient
and deeply inscribed property of the
universe that we see male like and
female-like behavior in something that
you know
for which those terms are in and of
themselves a stretch
if you understand them to refer to
gaming gaming right
if you get why the game plays out the
way it does it's not a stretch but
phylogenetically it does not refer to an
unbroken line of male like and
female-like behavior in all probability
but anyway I'm not sure about that I
don't think it makes sense to get hung
up on it the point is to the extent that
sexual reproduction has some role to
play in
this analog world that we have just
created
they just refer yeah it's a digital
world the AI has an analog world an
analogous World an analogous World
um
it is not obvious to me that it will not
generate an asymmetry that will to some
degree mirror a sexual asymmetry which
does not mean that it will make sense to
apply
those pronouns well so might there be
different strategies that indeed evolve
but if those strategies aren't actually
associated with
um with meeting types is the wrong word
here because then we're over in sort of
fungus land and there's a bunch and it's
like isogamous and it's not the same but
again it's if it's strategies that's
different from male and female
strategies are you know Downstream of
you know above it's like episexual
rather than sexual right right but
I don't disagree
with your point about we've got language
that's built around creatures that have
this you know creatures are very
different from each other but in this
regard they're really not right the
gamete size is highly predictive of the
characteristics that we attribute to sex
and this has nothing to do with people
it's nothing to do inherently with
software at all right it doesn't require
a brain right plants don't have brains
and yet we see them abide by these rules
um so put that aside the point is we and
I will get back to this issue about what
we don't know here in a second but
the thing is going to figure out
whatever mode upgrades it most rapidly
there's going to be some sort of a
competition between versions of this
thing yes and they are going to figure
out how to leverage things that are
going to cause emergence right you have
male and female inside the same species
that is a basis for emergence right the
lineage actually has the advantage of
both of these strategies in play
simultaneously
so this thing is going to come up with
its own version of that and we're going
to be scratching our heads looking at
what it's doing and saying oh that's
strangely male and then in other cases
we're gonna say well actually it's not
really male because X Y and Z we don't
know how that's going to play out but
anyway it is going to be an awful lot
like what would happen if you took an a
terrestrial biologist and pointed them
at extraterrestrial biology
the answer is actually to what degree do
we expect something that we recognize
and to what degree do we expect our
preconceptions based on what goes on
down on Earth to mislead us because we
won't be able to see what's in front of
us that's happening now with this thing
or at least it will
foreign
[Music]